it was a big day for movies like the
power of the dog
and dune but not such a good day for a
lot of big names who were left on the
outside looking in
to get an oscar nomination is an
absolute honor i think my first child is
going to be nangucci our name
sweetie yup lady gaga and jared leto
were a-listers who got snubbed so was
leonardo dicaprio who will be far more
catastrophic jennifer hudson also didn't
get any oscar
but for will smith it's good to be king
it is such a beautiful
honor it's a woman who know how to thank
yes daddy will's up against denzel
washington for best actor king richard
is also nominated for best picture i had
secretly felt that i would never make
anything better than the pursuit of
happiness then i saw king richard and
the film is good for this queen ain't
nobody knock it beyonce goes
head-to-head in the original song
category with brother sister pair billy
eilish and phineas for no time to die
and it's a family affair for these two
can you even imagine navigating award
season with your husband by your side
for a journey like that we try not to to
think about that too much penelope cruz
and javier bardem each grab lead acting
nominations oscar newbies and fiances
kirsten dunst and jesse plemons are both
up for the power of the dog which leads
with a dozen noms better than okay like
very okay
kristen stewart's invited to the oscars
march 27th on abc one of nine
first-timers including west side stories
ariana debose who posted this shocked
reaction
[Music]
by virtue of being a black woman the
interpretation is already different
people of color are represented in all
but one acting category 20 years after
monster's ball cemented halle berry in
oscar history what do you remember about
that i was having an out-of-body
experience
oh my god
russell crowe said breathe might breathe
mate i stood up there and i spoke from
my subconscious because i had no speech
this door tonight has been opened it was
a night that you know changed the course
of my life
[Music]